نجوم تركيا قلب واحد في حمله تجمع 6
مليارات دولار والزعيمه الشيشاني يدعو
الرئيس الاوكراني لاتخاذ هتلر قدوه وفشل
محاوله هروب مجرم بوليفي بس للامانه يعني
ممكن نعطيه علامه كامله على المجهود
والابتكار اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
تمكنت حمله تبرعات اطلقتها 213 محطه
تلفزيونيه و562 اذاعه داخل تركيا بالاضافه
الى قنوات واذاعات في اذربيجان وقبرص
التركيه تحت عنوان تركيا قلب واحد من انه
تجمع سته مليارات دولار خلال 7 ساعات من
البث المباشر لاغاثه متضررين الزلزال في
تركيا الحمله شارك فيها اهم واكبر النجوم
الاتراك ولاقت دعم شعبي كبير واهتمام
سياسيين رياضيين ويعني الاهتمام حقيقه
تمثل بحجم المبلغ كمان اللي تم جمعهم وعلى
فكره الحمله ببساطه هي بث مباشر على كل
منصات مثل ما قلنا وفيها النجوم على مراحل
شاركوا عبر تقديم البث وتلقي اتصالات
المتبرعين بانفسهم
[موسيقى]
ومن ايام كمان انطلقت حمله تبرعات شبيهه
في سوريا حملت اسم لاهلي والبث المباشر
فيها استمرت 72 ساعه عبر اثير اذاعه شام
اف ام من دمشق وكمان شارك فيها عدد من
الفنانين السوريين والاعلاميين لكن لافت
في هذه الحمله انه ما في اي اخبار عندكم
جماعه للان والحمله لسه شغاله وتمت
تمديدها 12 ساعه اضافيا وحنشوف عاد بعدها
يعني حيعلنوا المبلغ او لا وعلى فكره في
سوريا للان ما في اي احصائيه للخسائر ولا
اي معلومات عن حجم الدمار في المناطق
المتضرره
[موسيقى]
ورغم الدمار ورغم مرور اكثر من 250 ساعه
على الزلزال لا زالت معجزات الانقاذ
مستمره وفي ناس بتطلع عايشه من تحت
الانقاض في تركيا فتم انقاذ فتاه اسمها
الينا بقهرمان مرعش بعد 248 ساعه
[موسيقى]
وفيها تايتم انقاذ ام وطفلين بعد 228 ساعه
تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
ومن بين الفيديوهات اللي خطفت قلوب الناس
فيديو لمنقذين بحققوا طلب طفل انقذوه من
تحت الانقاض وطلب بس
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله
وامتنان الاطفال قالت لي طبيبها انت حتروح
على الجنه
بس اكيد راح
[موسيقى]
كنت اشوف الله هذاك كنت
بهاي شو اسمه الله هداك وجدتنا
[موسيقى]
وحبيتنا وكل شيء مصر تعبنا علينا
انت راح اكيد رايحه
اكيد انا حاسس راح تروح
[موسيقى]
وفي الاخير في صوره لطفل سوري بمحافظه حلب
جسد معنى الصمود والامل بصوره وهو بيبيع
غزل البنات وسط الدمار ومبتسم وكانه بوصل
رساله انه الحياه مستمره والامل موجود
وبما انه بنتكلم عن الاطفال والزلزال ففي
جانب كنا تناولناه من قبل وهو اثر الزلزال
النفسي على الناس بمختلف اعمارهم وحتى ان
كانوا جايبين منه او بعد ففي معلمه تركيه
بتشرف على عدد من الاطفال اللي تشردوا
موجودين ضمن عباره في ميناء الاسكندرون
تحولت لمستشفى ميداني لاحظ التاثر الاطفال
بالزلزال وسيطرته على عقولهم فالاطفال
هناك بداوا يلعبوا لعبه اسمها الزلزال
فبيعملوا بنا بالعابهم وبيسالوا بعض اذا
كان هذا المنح هيتحمل الزلازل او لا وغير
اللعبه مجسمات وسيارات الاطفاء اللي
بيستخدموها كمان خلال لعبهم عشان يروحوا
لمنطقه الزلزال ويساعدوا الناس طبعا خلال
اللعبه طبعا وفي اخصائيه نفسيه كمان في
نفس المكان قالت انه في اطفال بيعانوا من
صعوبه في النوم ونوبات البكاء المفاجئه
[موسيقى]
في خبر مفجع بصراحه جرينا اليوم وعليه
علامات استفهام كثير الخبر بيتكلم عن
تسجيل اصغر اصابه في العالم بالزهايمر
لمراهق صيني عمره 19 سنه والخبر نازل في
مجله طبيه كمان الاغرب اكثر واكثر ان
المريض ما عنده اي تاريخ من المرض في
العالم ولا عنده اي طفره جينيه بتسبب
المرض قبل تسجلت حالات زهايمر لمرضى باول
العشرين والثلاثين لكن جميعهم كان عندهم
الطفره او الاستعداد الجيني بحسب الدراسه
اللي صار مع الشاب انه بدا من عمر 17 سنه
يشكي من ضعف في شويه في الذاكره ومشاكل في
التركيز وردات فعل متاخره وصعوبه في
القراءه ولمن راح عند الدكتور كانت حالته
صعبه لدرجه انه مو فاكر ايش اكل قبل بيوم
وكانت طرق خلاص انه يترك المدرسه اللي كان
في اخر سنه فيها الزهايمر يعني مثل العلم
المعروف انه يصاب فيه الناس من 65 سنه
وطالع وبين خمسه لعشره في المئه فقط من
المصابين في ناس بيكونوا اصغر من كده
الدراسه في المجله العلميه قالت انه قد
يصبح حل الغ الاشخاص او الشباب المصابين
بمرض الزهايمر احد اكثر الاسئله العلميه
تحديا في المستقبل لكن بغض النظر عن
التحدي العلمي الناس مفجوعه من الخبر
وبتقول كمان يعني انه مرض جديد بدا يصيب
الشباب وهل المفروض يسوي شيء نحاول نحمي
نفسنا المفروض كمان نخاف يعني
المخ والاعصاب عشان يساعدنا انه نفهم من
هذا الموضوع اهلا فيك معانا تحت الهوا لما
تكلمنا
قلت لي انه قد ما يكون زهايمر ايش ممكن
يكون اذا ما كان زهايمر يا مرحبا طبعا
يعني هناك اسباب كثيره جدا لحدوث مشاكل في
الذاكره والتركيز
وفي نفس المنطقه التي تحدث فيها يعني
الزهايمر
الاسباب كثيره ومتعدده خاصه عندما تحدث
لدى صغار السن في هذا العمر في الغالب
تكون مرتبطه اما بعد الذاكره او شيء متعلق
بطفرات وراثيه مختلفه او متعلق بالحاله
النفسيه والصحه النفسيه
مثلا
الاكتئاب الشديد عدم تمرين الذاكره نقص
الفيتامين الذاكره هذا شيء مقلق ايش يعني
عدم تمرين الذاكره عدم تمرين الذاكره الان
نحن كل شيء على الذاكره الالكترونيه لا
احد يقول لا ارقام لا يحفظ حتى
المنازل يعني في السابق كان يعني نذهب لاي
مكان بالذاكره كما يحدث يعني في البلاك في
لندن الان على يعني اي مكان يعني حتى
الانسان لا يركز يعتمد فقط على الماب وعلى
يعني كل شيء على ذاكره فالذاكره تضمر كما
تضمر العضلات يعني اذا لم يتم تمرين بس
احنا بندرس وجالسين بنقرا وبنسمع حكاوي
بعض ويعني وحتى برضو على التليفون جالسين
بتسوي اشياء برضه يعني بتعلق بذاكرتنا هذا
ما يعتبر تمرين لا لا لا يعتبر تمرين هي
لا تعلق يعني هي تمر على الذاكره مرور
الكرام وتعلق باهداف الذاكره الموبوءه
بالنسيان في هذا الزمن تمرين الذاكره حفظ
يعني اشياء
قصائد طويله
حفظ في السابق كان يحفظون القران الكريم
يحفظون معلقات يحفظون يعني يعني كل شيء
مرتبط بالذاكره حتى الذين يقودون في
الصحراء يحفظون الطرق والنجم فالذاكره
دائما تكون متوهيه اما مشاكل الذاكره في
الوقت الحالي ليست كلها تمرين
لا تعتبر تمرين للذاكره هي هي
لكنها تمرين
للقدرات الذهنيه المختلفه سيكون بس صادقه
معك راح احفظ معلقات ولا حسوي يعني الامور
ولا حشوف حاحفظ طرق ولا كذا حلعب على
الجوال افضل يعني او سلوكه انا بيتي معرفه
ادله يعني طيب وهذه حقيقه وليست مبالغه
على الهواء بس خليني ارجع للموضوع عشان
الخبر اللي شفناه صادم اذا كان زهايمر هل
الزهايمر ممكن يصيب الصغار بهذا السن
وخصوصا انه بيقولوا لا عنده تاريخ في
العيله يعني ولا جينات
هو هو يعني ليس من المؤكد بالفعل انه هو
الزهايمر لان الزهايمر التشخيصه بنعم من
البروتينات
والفيتامين وهذه لم توجد في هذا الشاب
الصيني وجدت فقط في السائل الشوكي يعني
توجد في المخ وحتى وان كان الزهايمر فهو
حاله نادره جدا يعني لا تعتبر شيء يثير
القلق والخوف فقد تكون حدثت نتيجه اما
انها طفره جديده لم ترصد بالطفرات السابقه
المتعلقه
بجينات الزهايمر ولم توجد فيه تكون طفره
قد يكون التهاب فيروسي نوع من الفيروسات
التي تؤدي الى تغيرات في في يعني معروف ان
ماده الماده البروتينيه المعروفه التي
تسبب جنون البقر لدى الانسان جاكوب
جنون البقر انتقل عن طريق
ما يعرف بشيء يسمى فيروس البريون
ولا تعرف حقيقته بالكامل الى الان ايضا
فيروس الذي يسبب نقص المناعه المكتسب قبل
ان الايدز ايضا يسبب ديمنشيا وضمور
في الذاكره بس سريعا الان هم بيقولوا انه
التحدي المستقبلي حيكون في يعني معرفه
اسباب اصابه الصغار بالسن بالزهايمر والان
سرنا بنشوف امراض كنا معتدين انه عاده
يصابوا فيها الكبار في السن بنشوف الان
صغار بيتم تشخيصهم فيها ايش اللي متغير
اذا في شيء متغير
المتغير نمط الحياه كله متغير
والتلوث الذي يحدث التلوث البيئي والتلوث
الالكتروني وطبيعه الغذاء وطبيعه ممارسه
يعني
الحياه من النوم المبكر من حالات القلق من
حالات الاكتئاب حالات التوتر يعني هناك
اشياء كثيره جدا تغيرت حتى الساعه
البيولوجيه تغيرت يعني الناس لا ينامون
النوم الكافي في الوقت المناسب يعني
لان الكثير من الهرمونات والمواد الغذائيه
وعمليات الاكسده تتم في اوقات معينه يعني
الليل يعني
شخصت حاله كل الناس اللي يعرفهم ما ابغى
فاول على نفسي سلامه قلبي يعني من اي شيء
بس انه كل الناس كده يعني استغفر الله
العظيم
عشان كده كلهم يشكون يعني الان مثلا انا
في عيادتي للمخ والاعصاب قبل عشر سنوات
كان معظم المرضى كبار الصين الان معظمهم
صغار السن الذين يشكون بالقلق من الصداع
من التوتر من النسيان يعني كل هذه من
الارتجاف في اليد هزات عدم توازن تنمل في
الجسم الاشياء كلها يعني صارت لدى صغار
السن طيب اوكي الحمد لله يا دكتور يعني
معز انتهى وقتنا لليوم لانه كنت يعني
حتجيب لي انهيار عصبي انا كمان يعني فكان
معنى عز بخيت استشاري المخ والاعصاب شكرا
لك شكرا
مشاهدينا فاصل ونعود جاني اكتئاب
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد رمضان قد يروف رئيس الشيشان
معروف بولاء لروسيا وفي مقابله تلفزيونيه
وجه رساله للرئيس الاوكراني عدو روسيا
نحوها انه يا ريت تسوي مثل ما [__] هتلر
اذكركم هنا انه هتلر انتحر باطلاق النار
على
نفسه
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
احنا
[موسيقى]
طيب عارفين ايام المدرسه زمان في
الامتحانات لما كنا نحل مثلا مسائل مسائل
الرياضيات مثلا او كيمياء وتيجي الاجابه
النهائيه خطا بس انه مثلا يعني المدرسه او
المدرسه يعطونا كم علامه كده تقديرا للجهد
يعني بس في الحل كده يعني علامه كده بس
عشان شرف المحاوله يعني في اليوم خبر من
بوليفيا ذكرني بعلامات الترضيه هذه او
خليني اسميها علامات جهد يحترم بس على
الفاضي ففي مجرم في بوليفيا محكوم 15سنه
بجريمه قتل حاول يهرب من السجن وصراحه
محاوله مبتكره جدا يعني لو ينفع نحييه
عليها كان حيينا لكن طبعا قوه خرق للقانون
وهذا كمان يعني جهده كمان كله طلع على
الفاضي وبدون فايده وانمسك ترى في النهايه
فالسجين هذا اتنكر على شكل خروف ولبس صوف
على ظهره وغافل الحراسه للسجن وطلع من
زنزانته وبس وصل برا عند حقول السجن نزل
على اربعه بتنكر وهذا وصار يزحف الى ان
وصل لحدود السجن الخارجيه وحاول يتخطاها
ويهرب كل هذا زحف اربعه واستغل المطر
والظلام المهم حراسه السجن انتبهت
وانتبهوا بزنزانته وفق مدوروا عليه الا
جيو برا جالس يزحف يعني غير رجعوه المكان
وفرضوا كمان عليه عقوبات قانونيه وتاديبيه
على المحاوله هذه يعني
[موسيقى]
والى خبر عن جريمه اخرى وهذه فعليا ما
ينقال عليها الا بئس الفلوس اللي تخلي
واحد يفاول على اولاده وكذا ففي الاردن تم
القبض على اب وابنته بتهمه الاحتيال على
ثلاث شركات تامين بما مجموعه مليون و400
الف دينار اردني يعني تقريبا اثنين مليون
دولار الاحتيال كان بفبركه وفاه البنت
للحصول على ثلاثه بوليصات تامين القصه انه
الاب اللي بيشتغل في السياحه من سنتين طلع
لبنته اسمها البتول ثلاثه بوليصات تامين
على هذا عادي لموضوع قانوني يعني وبعدين
تفاجا الجيران والاقارب بوفاه البنت
بجلطان فتح عزا وجنازه وشيخ بيدعي واندفنت
البيت او اندفنت البنت في مقابر وفي شاهد
باسمها كمان بعدين الاب كلف ثلاثه محاميين
كل واحد منهم انه يبدا يطالب شركه من
الثلاثه بوليس للتامين الشركات بدات زي
العاده انها تتحقق من كل التفاصيل قبل ما
تصدر قيمه البوليصه قام اكتشفت واحده من
الشركات انه البنت كان عندها حاله طبيه
مزمنه ما اعلنت عنها وقت ما طلعت البوليصه
وهذا مخالف للقانون فقالت انه خلينا نبحث
اكثر في القصه ولما بحثوا اكثر اكتشفوا ان
البنت في لها ثلاثه بوليسات تامين على
الحياه والثلاثه لصالح والدها تستغربوا او
كذا قالوا خلونا نبحث اكتر واكتشفوا عاد
اشياء اغرب مثلا انه البنت توفت في مستشفى
شهاده الوفاه طالعه من مستشفى ثانيه هذا
غير انه تصريح الدفن طالع بعد اسبوع من
الوفاء وما في اي وثيقه تثبت انها دخلت
ثلاجه موته في اي من خلال هذه المده فراحت
الشركات بلغوا السلطات السلطات راحوا
يتحروا قام دقوا على باب بيت الاب قام
فتحت لهم بنت سالوها انت مين قالت لهم
البتول وهنا انكشفت القصه والسلطات امرت
بنفس القبر ويعرفوا مين اللي اندفن لقي
جوا القبر لعبه بلاستيك بحجم انسان كده
مكفنه السلطات تحركت وانقبض على الاب
والبنت وسته اشخاص اخرين من اصل ثمانيه
متورطين معاهم واحد منهم هربان لسه الثاني
برا البلد لانه
بيعمل عمره ما شاء الله عليه يعني اللهم
قوي ايمانهم فينا فعليا لا تعليق
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا لخدام حلقه اليوم ونعود
والقاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع المقبل في
امان الله
[موسيقى]